Knee arthroscopy is used in
the diagnosis and treatment
of a number of knee
disorders and injuries.
One common use is in the
treatment of meniscal tears.
Under normal
conditions, the menisci,
C-shaped pieces of cartilage
resting between the femur
and tibia, provide
cushioning and stability
for your knee joint.
Injuries, or arthritis,
can cause the menisci
to become torn, resulting
in knee pain, swelling,
and diminished range of motion.
Knee arthroscopy
is often performed
to remove the damaged
portion of the meniscus.
When you arrive at the
hospital for your procedure,
an intravenous line
will be started,
and you may be given a
sedative to help you relax.
The procedure can be performed
under spinal anesthesia, which
keeps you numb from
the waist down;
local anesthesia, which
keeps your knee area numb;
or less commonly,
general anesthesia, which
renders you unconscious for
the duration of the procedure.
An arthroscopic
meniscectomy usually
takes between 45 and 90 minutes.
Your surgeon will gain
access to your knee joint
by using sharp instruments,
called trocars,
to make two or three
small openings, or ports.
He or she will inject
a sterile solution
into the joint to push
the surfaces apart
allowing the structures
inside the joint
to be viewed more easily.
Next, your surgeon will
insert the arthroscope
and other instruments
through the various ports.
Images from the
arthroscope's camera
are magnified and projected
onto a video monitor.
Your surgeon will carefully
examine the inside of your knee
joint, locate the damage, remove
any loose or severely injured
parts, and use a
shaving instrument
to smooth any jagged edges.
While it may be possible
to repair the meniscus
with small stitches,
in most cases,
the damaged portion
must be removed.
At the end of the
procedure, your surgeon
will, again, carefully
examine the entire knee
for any areas of
bleeding or other damage,
remove the arthroscope
and other instruments,
and close each of the keyhole
incisions with a few sutures.
After your surgery, you'll
be taken to the recovery area
for monitoring where
you will be given pain
medication as needed.
Most patients leave the
outpatient surgery unit
within a few hours.